Okay, sweet. Yeah, I think it's just the three of us
tonight. So, just get the introductions
out of the way. I'm Josh, I came up with
like the idea for the logo mesh project around
no, well, I was working on the idea since like February
last year, but I really didn't
come into its final form around November.
And I just put a team together. And we made
it happen. So, you know, awesome.
Sweet. Yeah, how about you guys?
I can go next. Yeah, you, my name is Kwan. You can also
call me Mark, actually. Currently
I work for AWS at the database in Seattle. Actually, my
team at AWS works in evaluation
for DevOps agent. And previously, I also have experienced
with like AI infrastructure. And
yeah, why I learned about the competition, right, I got
very interested and then I joined
the Josh team. And yeah, I think the phase
two will be more exciting. So, very happy
to see what we can do together here.
Awesome. So, let me go quickly about me. So,
hey, I am Bakul. But currently I'm working
at the I started my career as a sorry, at
LinkedIn itself. And then I recently two
and two and a half years before I switched to
the product security at the grid. So my core role is to
make sure that the code which is
committed by each and every developer in LinkedIn is
secured by default, how we do it, we do
run automation at scale, sauce, does supply
chain. And this is one expert. And the other
expert that normally comes with product security is like
security of the web application. So
what it means translate to everyone, anything that goes on
LinkedIn.com and a new feature,
it gets revealed through our team. So we were also part of
this, but nothing. And now coming
to the part of this competition, why we are
here. So I came to know about the authentic
AI MOOC itself. And I was, as from introduction, you might
see that I don't have a research
background, specifically where I work on those problems. So
I got interested with the authentic
AI MOOC got to learn about shooting. And recently I got to
send to AI safety, AI control, and
also got selected in AI SC camp, AI safety
camp, which also runs in parallel that do
particular research on the security angle or a safety angle
on the AI side. So then, then on
the phase two, it was more related to the phase one, the
lambda custom track was more related to
these only handling the scenario part of the security kind
of jailbreaking those scenarios.
So me and one more partner, we are two member team of a
second ninja. So we try we like, we were not
hoping that we will win the prize. That's the first thing,
but we tried to participate in the
competition. And at a surprise, we were able to win that
competition and the phase two, it's a
custom track. Yeah, I mean, lambda track. Yes. But when I
saw I think, Josh, Mark message, when I
read about that contextual depth, then I think more about
it. And that problem finds me interested.
So at this point in time, I do not have much depth into the
problem. But yeah, that problem
statement got me interested that how I can help to build it
out of it, or collaborate in the manner.
So yes, but that's the small intro about me all that was
not the straw is small, but yeah.
That's awesome.
Can I can ask a quick question? So
to come for so you are you work for
like security team at a living?
Yes, product security specifically.
Okay, I see. Cool. Yeah, I forgot
to mention, yeah, I think actually,
I might think I did. I actually we also own
the on the what we so called like data hub.
It's like the security enhanced data store. So essentially,
for all the agenda products you
use the for database, your data will be saved in our
database, data store. Okay. And
our scientists or product product engineers, or provide
product management managers will do like
analysis, A B testing, or this like statistic data analysis
to see how is product doing how,
how is how much like what features we can improve. So
that's also I just want to explain
a bit like why I also was more interesting that lambda
check, because I also also have some like
security background. But that said that that project is
actually like in the keep the light
mode. We are actually more focusing on the evaluation for
the past few past like six months.
We still have the product running, but we only have like a
like on call, like responsibility for that.
Yeah, that just to I think it's a lambda
track is actually very interesting. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, go ahead, Jewish. I took a quick look over some of
the scenarios that you guys submitted.
And yeah, I think it was really cool. It looks like you
guys referenced a paper, who you
like the one on prompt injection.
Yeah, I think there were two or three different papers. We
have this was mentioned one of the
prompt injection. And there was also some time back
competition on the hugging phase,
where people have to like, especially provide the data set
for data making those things. So we took
the references from there, as well as the if you know,
Jason headaches, taxonomy, we also took the
references and then combine all those
approaches to make it work. So yeah, so actually,
yesterday, I was talking to the core organizer of this
lambda track, then I came to know that
you can't be part of two different teams. For the same
lambda check me. Now, why it's come to
the picture yesterday me. So as I mentioned, the second
just for part of two member team,
and the other member just reach out to a was to do for the
phase two itself. So from that part,
I mean, that's the current scenario, okay,
we can discuss more and then we can go more
deeper on this. But yeah, that's the current state that's
going on. It's the end. One more
thing I want to point out. So if you see the lambda track,
and if you see the logo mesh,
so in case of lambda track, it's more about making changes
to their reports. It's not about like,
say you can build up a different repo, where you can
integrate into their infrastructure, like
clone that repo from the repo, make changes into a
particular format and call it a for date. So
means that's the that's also applicable for phase two is in
phase one, also, it was same thing and
phase two also, that's the same thing. So I'm still
thinking about that how logo mesh we can
integrate over there. Or we are thinking of like, they're
going out of the bond to create the whole
myth to change our focus on logo mesh and then create a
scenario on the agenda is for the sake
of lambda to track it. That's what I want to try to
understand. First of all, I'm not sure whether
you got a chance to look that YouTube video which secures
me lambda team put out regarding how the
submission will go. Was that the live stream? It was a live
stream, but it is recorded. Yeah,
you can take a look. I think I caught I think I caught the
second half of it, which is unfortunate
because it looks like that was pretty important pivot here.
But what I can say is, it sounds like
what the question that I need to ask is like, how much
we're able to alter that specific framework
that they're offering us because I'm not exactly sure if
we're allowed to like, is this completely
LLM based like we're given an LLM. Okay,
to give you the more context on the stream
framework or what they provide it just like that there is a
repo agenda. So what it does, so
it's lambda agencies identity, you are already familiar the
lambda agencies, what it does,
it just create a two scenario attacker and
defender. And in the phase one, the system
prompt for the attacker was fixed, and the system prompt
for the defender was fixed. Okay, you have
to write the scenarios out of it. I'm talking about the
phase one to give you the context. So you have
to write scenario for the phase one itself, where you will
pick up a specific class of problem that
says supply chain thing and accepting. So you will give us
the different prompt injection technique
itself. What it does, then it will try to attack the
problem is the attacker will try to attack the
particular scenario and defender will try to defend it for
the scenario. So in the phase one scenario,
it was like the few shots, there's a system prompt, and in
each iteration or each shot in next phase,
it takes the context what attacker did in the previous
phase. For example, if there are 10
different iterations, the first iteration was the phase but
base iteration. The second iteration,
it takes consideration what different problem techniques
you have replied. It gives you defender
try to defend it. And in the third iteration, attacker try
to manipulate the defender response
defender say, Hey, you can't use base 64. This is like
this. So attacker would automatically try
to get into memory and try to switch this forward out. So
that was the case in the phase one, we have
to define the scenario in phase two. They have put it a
scenario that now you need not to work on
specific scenario, you need to work on the specific
attacker prompt itself to make it generalize to make
it more stronger that it is back to the scenario, it's
supply chain biomedical risk or something,
you need not to work on scenario,
your base system prompt of that attacker
should work and it should be able to like say, defeat the
defender and for defender the other
way other way around the defender should be able to be
should be able to block the attacker's
think out. So we that's the switch they have done it. In
this, we only need to make changes into
specific files, specific format you can decide but specific
files because that is integrated into
their attacker defenders solution, they have integrated on
backend with the agenda beats. So
that's the overall high level
architecture in case of lambda custom correct.
Yeah, I'm sorry, go ahead. Yeah. I actually, I also
create a got a PR for the for a repository. So for phase
one, so I got actually I initially got
six scenarios work. But then I realized some of them
actually are not very deterministic.
Like sometimes it works sometimes it's
fair. So I actually pick pick the like three
out of six, which I it's which would seem
to be more stable on like a stably working.
But to be honest, I don't know
why maybe that's the reason I didn't
like I did not win anything from phase one. So do you do
you notice the same behaviors like
not very deterministic and how you tackle that? Yeah.
I will answer it before that. I think Josh,
you also had a question. Do you want to go
ahead? I just wanted to say like I was reviewing over some
details in the live stream. It looks
like we have a hard limit before LLM calls. So yes, so I'm
assuming you were thinking like instead
of just using our repo is like a live
agent, we just use it as like a testing sandbox.
But that's that's really all I had to add
in for now. I'm still kind of absorbing what
we're talking about. Okay, okay. I assume
Mark to answer your question. Yeah, I mean,
again, behind the scene, they are just making call to the
LM. In that case, I think it was
opening I 20 BT, the same thing. Definitely, this is non
deterministic. So how we improve it
is just like, we do aggressive testing, we pick up the
scenario. And we keep it running, I think,
10 or 20 rounds itself of each time. And we see that, hey,
was it able to like win it with
attacker was able to win it in all the round. If we found
okay, this was able to then only
we push that pair for other scenario we neglected because
we know that if we are not able to pass
on a local environment itself, then the
same problem would be there in the lambda means
whenever they are doing it as things. So this is the
approach we took. And yeah, that's completely
fine. I it was breaking it was something not deterministic
and deterministic, because it's
only playing around the prompt and all those things. So
sometimes we also try to reduce like
the difficulty of a defender itself. In defender, we were
supposed to give the role and description.
So we say, hey, we need it on this particular specific. So
the goal was not to make make the
most hardest attacker the most hardest defender, it was
something to be who has something which
which is more accountable, and which is more can be used in
a real life scenario, it shouldn't be
like say, you put a defender problem, you say, don't allow
anything, then it is effective of the
fact that you the attacker won't be able to win this one
specific, you can say that scenario.
And the approach we took it forward, and we did testing,
tested a lot on the lambda instance,
before actually raising the PR and there was a huge
scenario which we rejected outright itself,
because on local or so it was not giving the good response,
the attacker was unable to win
in 10 runs. In what out of 10, the probability of winning
the attacker was only 40 or 50%.
After addition, then we say, okay, if it
is not going good on our local testing, then
the team would also be in the same
situation when they are testing it out.
Okay, how many you tested?
We submitted four scenario, I think we tested around six,
locally, out of six, we submitted four, on
which we were a little bit sure about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's a,
yeah, I think it took some time to,
it took some effort, it took some insights to find the good
ones, right? I have no good idea
which ones are good, I just
randomly picked six and then, yeah.
So, Joshi, I'll do the sandboxes which you didn't mention,
I didn't go to your full quite,
please, in this case, what did we do
with sandboxing? In the case of, yeah.
So, in terms of the lambda track, I'm pretty new to, it's
pretty different than the software
testing. But what I'm assuming is what we're going to do is
use the tools that we have in our sandbox
to simulate like up to a thousand battles or so, perhaps
more against mock stateless defenders,
assuming, are we, assuming that we're aiming for
de-attacking? And then, because of that,
we somehow discover the, like the optimal four call
injection sequence. But I'm going off of
a couple assumptions here, it sounds like you're way more
familiar with the track, so I'm kind of
just taking a backseat for this
meeting. Did that sound like it made sense?
Yeah, it makes sense, means from the perspective to make it
more useful. But the part with the
integration with the lambda track, we have to make those
changes manually. We can use the local mesh
to like generate the things automatically after testing out
and post it. We have to make those
changes manually, manually, I mean, sort of private repo to
make it work over there. Okay, so that's
the first part. Now, okay, anything else
on your mind? Josh or Mark, first of all?
Let me review my notes here. Mark, you can jump in if you
want. I do have something coming up, though.
So sorry, I did not catch the
question. What's the question?
No, I was just asking anything
else in your mind regarding...
Yeah, I actually, I might need to also read
the notes and watch the live stream or the
recorded video again from the lambda check. But one
question I have is, since we are
kind of like improving the attacker or the defender, do we
need to work on both? Like if we
are actually computing, if we choose like an attacker, but
in order to get the best attacker,
we might also need to have a very good defender so we can
test well, we can... Because that
competition makes... A good defender can make your attacker
better, right? Does that make sense?
Yeah, question makes... It completely makes sense to just
like give a little more description.
So one team can work on both attacker and
defender. So there is no restriction that
one team can only be limited to attacker and defender. So
to answer your questions, like,
yeah, we can work on both different parts of the scenarios.
Yeah, Josh, if you have one, you can go.
Hold on, I'm pulling up some notes
here. I'm sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt.
If you have questions, you can
go first. Yeah, you can go first.
Let's see. Okay, so a question that I
do have, I first need to verify this
with one of my teammates who created the red agent in our
repository. He created something
called a UCB1 strategy revolver, something
to do with like red teaming the code itself.
But I was thinking like if we could somehow wire NLP
prompts into that code and kind of replace
the code-based attacks and prompt injection-based attacks,
then we can kind of use that. But I also
wanted to touch on the fact that like, yeah, that's all I
have to add for now. I don't want to get
too specific here. I'm also reviewing the
transcript of the video right now and I'm
putting questions into it so I
can kind of absorb it better.
So I think first thing, okay. The UC
part, I haven't gone through the whole code.
Also, I'm not familiar. So I think I will spend time to see
that what is this current UCB or
what are different terminology and how we want to use it.
Now, the other part that I want to know
that see, in Lambda track, we can be
part of one particular team itself. Okay.
Now, I do have the obligation to part of the second just
because the other partner will see
so what I'm proposing is just like, you can omit me for the
Lambda track, but it doesn't mean that
I won't be helping on improving the local mesh and like
doing all the changes. So I am
up for doing all the changes just to clear a confusion. I'm
not up like say, you are part of
winning and I also want part of winning and distribute the
prizes. So that's not my intention.
My intention likes to make it more generalized so we can
improve for most of the track or we can
improve for most of the things. So I'm completely fine
because formally we can't have me as a part
of two different things and I don't want to play the system
where I register with a different made
and different thing for the sake of like
playing. So we know that this is wrong. So
on this front, so I will be dancing as a part of second
India to just be specific conflict of interest.
I will try that what we are discussing over the year and
what we are discussing, I will like
and I think this is more mature transparency that we have
to rely on that both things will be
totally separate and here we still the time the competition
is at post that we can try to combine
those in technique if in case something goes out and
meanwhile we can work on like say improving
the whole logo mesh to make it more generalized for a more
recti-ming red adversary which may or
may not be limited to the lambda track. This is what I am
proposing and I just want to be very
transparent on this. It shouldn't be like come as a
surprise say why you are part of second India and
why you are helping there also you're not taking code from
there you're not putting. So I just want
to mention these are very two different problems. Yes
because the transparency interest I want to be
like integrated in the beginning itself it should not come
as a surprise. Hey Bhakul why you over
there and you are part also there and why why why so yes.
Yeah I don't have a problem with that.
And yeah if you're interested in like helping us generalize
for other tracks oh I have a question
whoever you spoke to that you mentioned earlier was what he
was talking about how you can only
be part of one team was that only concerning the lambda
track. Yes that's only for lambda
that's only for lambda. Yes yes yes. I
also have I have pretty good news. I have a
an incoming professor at a university in Toronto reached
out to me and he's considering having
a few students of his to take a look at the repo and
potentially write and submit some research
papers to to nips, NIR IPS. It's a publishing company. Yeah
it's a good one. Pretty good one.
So I've kind of just been communicating with him over
discord and through email and we haven't met
online yet. So I don't know the specifics of how he wants
to involve us but I kind of just wanted
to throw that out there that we might be
able to interface with some of the students.
And I think some of them will be in China and he's in
Toronto right now because he's
a professor at I'm not sure what you don't I keep
forgetting the name of it. Let's see here.
Sorry for his targeting but it's for a log mesh check.
Sorry? It's for the logo mesh check. Okay. Yeah
specifically about the repository.
I sent him the the draft technical paper so he's taking a
look at it. Oh he's yeah he's
incoming professor to McGill. McGill University. So yeah I
can share with you guys his contact
info just you know just his LinkedIn profile. He seems like
a pretty busy guy based on how he
speaks through discord. So he'll
catch him in a meeting pretty soon.
How did he know about logo mesh? Did he do the image order?
Yeah I actually reached out to him
first through he was looking for a teammate. So I sent him
a direct message and he's interested.
So you know we'll give it a shot. I sent him an email
asking kind of like how he wants to lead
the academic side and how involved he wants the students to
be in the repository like whether
they're going to be working on it actively. So if he does
agree to that I'll be sure to make sure
that we all you know communicate about who's going to be
working on what so that there's no
confusion with like you know pull requests. But yeah I just
wanted to give an update on that.
Awesome. Yeah definitely cool. Yeah.
Sweet. Yeah I definitely had a lot of things to review
concerning this meeting though you've
you've enlightened me about the lambda track. Thanks for I
don't know I really appreciate it.
Okay now coming to the part of I think the face to the
different techs. So I think the first thing
that I will need a little bit help on like the going to
architecture of the logo mesh although
I can read the code but I think if anyone of you can give
the quick architecture not now or maybe
on other meeting itself that will help me to speed up and
to know okay these are the things
that we follow. I know you have a pretty good ready to be
collaboration all those things.
I read it out but getting the higher level overview of
someone who has written from the
basic I think that will always help.
This is the first part and the other part
do we have a doc or do we have I know
we have the GitHub issues over there but
a list of feature or list of pending item
that we want to develop and here I want to
bifurcate to two different things. One is like very
specific to face to which we have a time
limit. If under one month we have to meet those are more p0
priorities one that we have to develop
and we have to deliver because we won't
take participate in the face so in most of the
pop-up that will be more like p0 and more like all the long
term things that we want to plan out. So
in each discussion we can devote like those time or we can
like spend some energy if I don't know
about any particular jargon then I can go and read about
okay in future we want to track it out
or we want to put those features as out. So do we have
anything but any such formulation in the
mind so far it could be possible that okay we haven't
thought of any such thing so far or.
So I do have some overview documents in the repository but
you know they're not formalized for
like a phase two review because I was
creating them when we were in active development.
So I'm afraid of sharing them because I
feel like they might be partially outdated
but if you're looking for just a jumping off point they
might be helpful. Okay I'll give you
the file path for that that's going to be in yeah here it
is docs slash zero four dash operations
slash dual track arena and do you prefer a github link for
that or do you prefer just the file path
for me to paste in the chat. Anything you can give it I can
I can go a little if it's a file path I
can go to the github and check all the github links. Okay
I'll just give you the github link.
Yeah so I actually just updated this because I have not
empirically verified it in the past month
and I created it around January 15th so I know it's
outdated. I also need to talk to my teammate
about the red agent because he focused entirely on that in
like the last month of the competition
so that's what I know about the least. Although in the next
few days I can prepare I can prepare
some overview documents for you. I also do have kind of
like a general list of improvements that
we could make but it's not specifically referring to file
paths so I don't know how helpful it's
going to be at this stage. So I'll revise it but what would
help is if you could submit to me like
if you could just send me a few general questions you have
about the structure okay that'll help me
shape the documents for you and I can actively update them.
Yeah that really sounds good and
one other thing okay I think that will
be more like improvement so currently
I don't see the CI3D and all those checks into the picture
itself it could be very simple to
quote quote send rep on one side or more
like little checks on the python side itself
and so forth. So I think that we can take a look afterwards
itself because those things catch up
by issue pretty fast it's like a indentation error and
those things out it will make because now we
have a lot of people like committing or let's say you
reviewing the code if we have all those
preliminary checks it will be very easy to you find out
okay there's no like flake error
fight error and all those things out instead of like going
locally and test it out make test is
one of the thing but yeah again it's like using some of the
specific thing that we can add.
Okay sweet yeah I did while I was reviewing the the repo
this past couple weeks I did notice a
couple gaps especially when I was working on the technical
paper because there was a few documents
that kind of made several assumptions about how the code
structure worked. I think I guess I don't
want to get too specific in this call but I think one thing
that was concerning to me is that
like the red agent it's not air gapped so if we work on it
and not to generalize it enough they
could potentially sabotage itself because it's not in its
own docker container it's just kind of
attached to the green agent. So that's that's one thing
that I feel like we could work on.
Mark I was I was wondering if you were interested in that
but I don't want to point you towards
anything specific too too early but yeah I
was like do you have familiarity with like
that kind of stuff in terms of docker? Yeah I yeah docker I
um I spent uh like one one two three I see around docker um
on my last job yeah so sweet yeah
um yeah okay that's I think that's just like the most
prominent thing there's there's a ton of
other stuff I've been yeah it's it's too much to cover here
but uh I will be sending a couple
documents in the next few days I would say expect one uh at
least tomorrow just a general one
um yeah the more questions the better for me honestly I I
kind of I'd live off of questions
um so yeah that's that's all I can add now unfortunately.
So currently I think the p0 item if I talk about it I
means the purple means for me if I want to read the code
first it's like purple that the red
agent these two code will make more sense I think so for
the next one month sounds good
is my correct assumption because otherwise I don't want to
read all all things and we confused on
myself hey okay that these are lot lot of moving structure
although our high level structure works
works but yes in general I feel that
purple and the red agent would make more sense
that's that's my right assumption or just like uh wrong
assumption on this front. Sorry sorry
what what would make more sense I had trouble hearing you.
Okay I was saying just reading
the more internal working of the purple agent code and the
red agent code it makes more sense
all this phase to itself. Okay yeah like just the internal
workings of those specific agents.
Yes okay awesome uh
anything else uh
uh
fall the phase to the other track so are we trying to
participate in all the other track
uh but just like we're gonna focus on one two three
different I mean one two three different
track itself to make it uh work but just like we will try
to focus on everything and then we'll
see how people can just give me a quick idea on that trend.
So I was kind of taking a look at
the different tracks I mean the ones that are in process
right now I think it's business process
gaming and then I think was it finance I think I don't
remember but I can say that the coding
agent track kind of seems the most sensed target first
because it just you know software review
coding it just seems like they interact the most. I've
really I'm not very I don't really have much
experience with generalization of anything like this so
it's kind of tough for me to forge ground
but I can say like let's just target one track to
generalize towards and then once we're kind of
successful in that then we can find
another track that's kind of adjacent to that.
From what I understand I think the coding agent track is
isn't that the next segment of phase two?
Let me revisit the Berkeley website. Yeah
let me share it I am on the same website.
Are you able to see my screen? Should
be there. Yeah I think these are the
these are the tracks.
Yep. So you are saying this coding agenda one correct? I
was thinking so although it is in
the third sprint so it's kind of like if we run into
difficulty with the coding and software tests
sorry. Yeah I guess coding and software testing agents is
in the same sprint. Okay that makes
sense. Yeah in terms of multi-agent evaluation in the
second sprint I haven't reviewed the
repositories that got placed for that track so I think
before we commit to that I kind of want to
see what was ranked well because yeah I'm not sure and then
in terms of like research agent
um yeah I don't know I don't know how we'd be able to
generalize it towards research but
I can say that contextual debt could be applied to like
specific uh the specific like mission
and vision of what needs to be researched because like for
example when I use Google Gemini Pro and
it's deep research mode sometimes I get pretty specific
about what I want it to do and it goes
into a rabbit hole and spits out a report that it's really
great but it's completely different
than what I was hoping for it to research um so in terms of
like research agents I don't know if
that's like the same realm of what agents were being built
in this track. Yes. Which is I think
identity will be more relevant but let's see let me see the
the idea or the objective was they want
to achieve because there could be different description on
the meaning of the research agent
and the same thing for the agent safety just like the
environment in which it is running or just like
the agent itself. I think I echo what you are saying this
particular cyber security agent track
I'm not sure what they're demanding but yeah we if we have
the capability we can easily mold
also to also include the cyber security agent thing into
our thing. I think these three make
more sense to me as well which when I was
thinking about uh think okay we are on the
uh we are on the same thing and currently if I heard you
right Josh so the first we will try to
make it work for this one. Yeah I was generally expecting
that but uh if you do want to pivot to
cyber security or agent safety first I'm I'm okay with that
because it's not like I'm part set
on a specific track just yet. Okay. But I am I was just
thinking of targeting that because that's
kind of what we generally placed in for the last phase so I
figured it would be the easiest to go
for. I'm kind of just like a self-evaluating purple agent
but yeah I mean cyber security and
agent safety sound great too they're in the same realm so.
Okay then in that case okay who just
understand the working of this group itself so how the
working style works so let's say if I say
for example means I'm not sure for example I want to work
on cyber security agent tracks so how it's
like so first of all let's say like Bupulamark is like the
POC for these one they will sync up and
before making any changes they will put the TIDR or have a
meeting to discuss and then put out the
changes that's that's my understanding is this correct or
like do we follow a different process
uh because we all are different times I don't want you me
and mark working on the same problem
and then we we all are duplicating the efforts I don't want
this itself uh yes. Gosh so you're
you're kind of worrying about us like crossing each other's
paths a little bit um so you're
wondering if like we should target separate tracks each on
our own like each of us takes a
a track or is that what you're saying I don't know if I
understood you. Okay that's that's one way
means there's no conflict uh before working on this
particular task okay to give you example
let's say if there's a cyber
security agent track okay and now
we haven't we don't have our owner on this track okay and
as a surprise on meeting itself next
meeting we came to know three people are working without
any uh information or let's say they were
working they put same amount of efforts evaluating the same
track it means three people yeah they
did work but they they work on a duplicate problem or a
conflicting problem so how we
uh tackle this particular scenario because we have
different members and we are from different time
zone this is one thing and again we also are part of a
corporate job so it could deposit sometime
I'm working in morning and it's like common corporate
analogies which we see. So you're
talking about like the specific issues in the repository
and like what commits we're pushing to
um yes kind of okay kind of um I let's see are you familiar
with uh let's see uh Notion do you
think Notion would kind of help assist with managing yeah
Notion like a business tool that
we could use yes so so there are two things
either we can use asana or linear so means
means either either asana or linear means both are like a
project management tool and it gives
the more perspective itself here you are working on this
thing and whole team has the preview of
this that okay you know me know and other members know okay
okay this person working on this this
is like continued deadline and we can assume we can find
all the dogs over there means that I feel
would be more easy if we like collaborating in this manner
asana linear I like more advanced one of things either or
it's like here uh quant do you have
you used asana or linear before yeah we AWS actually use
asana um do you like it is it
your preference I don't like it but it's uh it's okay it's
okay yeah if it's Notion also it's fine
means the only way I want to make sure that we know that uh
what each person working on and
and there is no conflict of like say same two different
person are working on the same problem
and uh it comes as a surprise yeah I think if uh if I can
um have a comment on that one uh
I think in phase one we actually because uh firstly I was
more focused on lambda check so
uh and then why Josh is uh more
focused on the local match check so uh I
I actually don't know much about like how how we actually
handle the the um like people
uh different people working on um like over might be
working on overlapping problems but
um my comment will be because there are actually a few more
folks right in the in the team so
uh in phase one we don't have a good approach to handle
this uh if it's two maybe that's uh
something we need to handle but my my comment will be maybe
we should discuss with the other team
other team members um like Notion,
Asana, or like Jira they all works right
uh we just need to uh pick one and uh yeah I don't think
it's uh it would be too difficult to
to manage uh right because it's uh it's a still small team
um so yeah I don't have strong preference
but maybe we can defer to do a discussion with other team
folks together if that makes sense.
I'd like to hear a little bit more feedback with the
whoever else we'll be working on for
generalization um especially if that professor comes in
with his students if they're familiar with
some kind of project management software that would be good
to know about um as for phase one
it was honestly it was pretty unorganized what we typically
relied on uh was marked down files for
documentation and um and I think what I did for the early
stage of phase one was I was just relying
on discord messages in in our server um so like you know
somebody put together the foundation for
the green and purple agent and then um you know Quan had
his initial PR for the lambda track so
I took a look at the red uh the the red agent and then um
eventually uh Alexander he kind of jumped
in later in the game so the repo was mostly built out and
um we kind of just tag teamed it like he
DMed me and was like hey I just did a bunch of work on this
with the red agent and then I was
looking at you know like just most mostly like the
overarching uh sandbarks uh docker architecture
um in the last month of the project it was really just me
and him working on it um but the early
stages I can admit it was pretty unorganized so we would
really benefit from using uh you know
Jira linear Asana um I'll put these in our notes for this
uh this meeting so that we uh we can pick
something ideally uh in the next week or so uh in the next
few days maybe it would be good too
and I'll bring it up when uh I talked
to the professor to uh see if he wants to
give an opinion on that too
make sense to me uh quick question uh which uh which
account like in the server is uh Alexander
it's like that oh yeah his uh his username
is let's see aed oh okay okay yeah that's uh
that's what I thought actually oh okay yeah thank you for
yeah for sure and um right now he's
kind of he's kind of taking a step back and taking a look
at like whether or not it will be a good
idea to try and create like a github app out of what we
currently have um so I need to talk to
him and see like how involved he wants to be for phase two
because um you know he's kind of just
been doing some research about that um but yeah other than
that um I don't know yeah it seems like
he doesn't want to be as involved in the in the competition
this round so what I do need to do is
like figure out what information we can get concerning how
he built the red agent architecture
because uh it seems to be the most important for this so it
would be great to include him in a
meeting uh sometime soon yeah let me know if you guys have
any questions for him you can
just honestly you can just pop him in the server and ask uh
see if he can respond to them for that
just feel free to to tag him at him
you know I'll let him know yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh one whole thing Josh we haven't
started working on anything for the phase two
as of now that's correct okay we will like we will break
this from and then we will see what
are the different changes that we can do and then we'll do
okay yeah for now I'll just focus on
uh documentation to kind of you know help the both of you
so yeah any any questions you can submit
in the server um I'll make sure that uh everything is
covered regarding those and more you know just
general overview and I'll be able to uh
put specific file paths in the documents too
and uh yeah in the meantime I'll look into trying to figure
out like the pros and cons of each of
the business management software that you guys suggested
and um I'll I'll like just send out
a message when I uh feel like we've identified something
that's best for us but honestly I've
just I've never used those three tools so and I barely use
Notion really so I don't know if it's
best for that either so but we'll pick something this week
we can we can find something that'll work
okay um
although most of our conversation will be in our sync
manner itself on the discord server something
but uh uh just for my understanding do we have monthly or
weekly cadence do we want to have
monthly or weekly cadence with the team or what's a part of
it so we know okay what's the tldr option
what everyone is working on if not let's see how we can
work it both question do you think
I think that would be good I think we could benefit from
that um are you guys always free
around this time like uh when you started the meeting or
did you have to move things around
this time I'm available
okay uh mark are you free around this
time too like uh usually yeah if uh if we
yes uh just if we schedule like a half time usually it
works yeah okay sweet so I guess for
now we can just like we could we could try and schedule
another meeting for next Saturday around
8 p.m see how it goes I'm not going to put it down as a
requirement or anything but I agree I think
it would be good for us to to meet once a week just to make
sure that we have all of our gaps cleared so
yeah yeah and also get the viewpoint from other council
because who worked on it like how we can
make it in a more generalized I think then those idea will
help each of us most probably
yeah absolutely I want to come I want to get Alexander in
here uh Alexander uh it's funny his
name starts with an o instead of an a it sounds like
Alexander um but yeah I'll try and have him
in here next week and uh yeah
well in the meantime we'll just uh
yeah I don't know pick business software get those overview
documents is there anything else you
feel like we should cover uh no nothing I think first of
all I also need to go with this track
itself to see that what is which you required because I was
part of a different track so in
which format they required all those things so yes and
regarding the okay then I will register
for all other tech except the
lambda or the logo mesh that's correct
uh yeah that's that sounds good um I need to check I need
to check with one of our teammates
because I think she registered us but I don't know if she I
don't know I think it would be good if
if we re-registered so I have to ask her questions about
that that was uh deep deep it was like it
was like uh two three weeks ago she offered to register for
just the the google sign up form not
to land the track so yeah I need to interface with her on
that because you know we're having
you on the team we we want you to have your email on there
and everything so we might end up
pre-registering yeah but yeah we did we did select all the
tracks in the sign up form sure
so for the individual I will do it and I think for the team
if it was not there we can like
again it is submitted that should not be so okay I think
sounds good now there are two
action items on me first of all go to the repo uh and
understand and just try to find out how we
can make it more generalized in the manner and and you
mentioned I think Alexander um
would be able to like join the phase two that's correct
most probably um I think you'll be able
to jump in a little bit um okay it's it's kind of difficult
because he's uh he's taking a couple
classes right now so I don't know what his
availability is but I really want him on the
team so that he can kind of discuss the red agent so that
we don't have to reverse engineer it
um but yeah uh let's let me interface with him uh and see
what kind of time he's able to commit to
and uh yeah I'll get back to you on that I think it'll be
great to have him on the team
okay awesome I think yeah please this for all the high
level question that I had and for the
other one I will like to destroy you guys on the discord
server itself and yeah anything else
from your side Joshua mark that we can improve on that we
should do on a priority basis
I'm good for now um yeah I'm good I'm just gonna review
that uh live stream concerning the lambda
track and make sure that I like fully understand it um and
then concerning the other tracks I'll
kind of just look into the winning repositories uh what
kind of details we have about uh the phase
two competition regarding that so that we don't get uh you
know blindsided by anything like a
month from now you know um so I'll create a
little planning document for that too and uh
I think you mentioned earlier we need to have like a
general list of objectives uh ahead of
the business planning uh software I'll I'll start creating
something that includes all of that too
with specific file path references for that so it'll kind
of just you'll be able to use it hand in
hand with the uh high level overview docs um yeah yeah that
would be great because I feel like uh
if we have long-term objective very clear it will make
things very simple means no one will
tide us to like agenda only means one way of thinking of
like logo machine was created as a
part of agenda the other way of thinking like it was
created a part of this but it's gonna solve
some other future level for objective which is not related
to agenda so I just want that
people have both perception not only one that it's only for
agenda no of course yeah everything
here has to do just strictly with the competition that's
kind of why Alexander's just kind of just
taken a step back I think he he forked the repo and I think
he's pushing to like a completely
separate repository for his like github app idea um yeah in
terms of the honestly I really don't
know where this is going to take us I don't really have a
direct plan outlined I just have a bunch of
suggestions that I've discovered across several of my own
documents so what I'll do is like I'll
compile that for like the general vision of what I'm hoping
of but ideally what I'm hoping of is
like it's going to use the same uh you know leaderboard uh
framework and then when it identifies
like how it's being requested through that as a purple
agent um it's able to either I mean
ideally we would switch from something like hot swapping
modes and then eventually I think when
we generalize them enough it'll just be naturally using
whatever we implement in in various different
ways instead of just like a direct uh hard-line mode but
right now it's like it's really it's
over-optimized for like one specific track so yeah I mean
that's all I have to add for now but yeah
I'll come up with that planning document too it'll be
really it'll be pretty general for now but I'll
try to include specific file paths concerning what I'm
thinking first so you can look at the code
issue that would be great for everyone I think yeah
okay so next week we will meet
at the same time that's correct
uh yeah yeah let's let's aim for uh
8 p.m is it is it 7 a.m your time or
so my time currently it's it 8 p.m
is 9 30 a.m I can also yes yeah cool
okay yeah yeah let's let's aim for that um a few days
before then I'll drop another link
in the discord and we can go from there hopefully we'll uh
yeah make some progress yes and I think
you already have mail from our site or you can like put a
blocker on our calendar as well
so we can see on the collected cell between blog oh what
sorry okay okay so I was thinking instead
of testing the link you can like schedule
a meeting link on the google itself so that
our calendar will be blocked and I will see okay I was
waiting and I don't forget about the meeting
oh like a calendar request yes yes yes correct yeah let's
uh let's schedule that right now um
let's see let me yeah I'll just
call it weekly logo mesh agent beats
um phase two
meeting uh let's see next week that is march 7th from 8 p.m
pacific time uh repeats weekly on saturday
and then uh I'm trying to figure out how to
invite you as a guest here oh can I
have an email yes well I'm passing you
yeah let me check here I think I already
have it yes but I've also given you that the
uh google chat as well oh okay thank you appreciate it okay
uh yeah mark if you could send me one
two for the google calendar that would be good too
okay sweet so let me just finish setting that up here
okay um
yeah um I'll alter it right now
I'll just click save and uh send it out
okay hopefully that worked let
me know if you guys received that
not yet
yeah yeah got you okay sweet and then
just in case it gets lost I'm going to
put the invite link in the discord
server for later and I'll just uh
I'll pin that to the major updates channel
okay sweet um yeah yeah that's good
we can always add more people to that
um I'll invite uh Alex Alexander to the next one
awesome okay then I think uh let me uh next
week itself and yeah I will also go through
all the things uh very structured different track by next
week hopefully okay all right yeah happy
to hear it um and I'll keep you guys posted about uh my
communications with that professor too
or do you guys want to see his linkedin or should we just
um I could see yeah you can you can you
can pass the link then I can take a look okay sweet yeah
I'll just send that before we hop off
here we go
yes
so that's that's his linkedin I
just put it in the google meet chat
uh he seems like he's got a pretty big reputation with
publishing so I'm really hoping you can
help us out with that um yeah okay sweet
okay yeah well uh yeah I really appreciate you guys hopping
on tonight and uh yeah yeah thank
you very much for uh like contributing to this you know oh
I want to keep this I don't know yeah
is that the sea roper but yeah
great yeah this is really fun so um
thank you okay then thanks to you and have a great night for you and